cloud code is a set of extensions for
the most popular development tools in
the market
the jetbrains family of ides such as
intellij
and visual studio code
in this video we'll cover the navigation
and capabilities of cloud code
using the vs code version cloud code
speeds up your development by
streamlining common workflows for python
go nodejs and java applications
merging non-trivial tasks into a simple
user interface
right in your ide this means no more
switching between your command line
cloud console and code editor tasks
like going through the loop of building
pushing deploying and debugging your
application
can be both burdensome and error prone
cloud code handles that for you
a key goal of cloud code is to enable
continuous development
by automating processes for example you
can rapidly iterate on a live kubernetes
cluster
or at a google cloud api to your
application
from your ide the first thing you'll
notice
when you install cloud code is the
welcome page this provides a summary of
the key supported features
and also has a direct link to creating a
new project from one of our starter
templates
let's take a look at what cloud code
adds to the vs code ui
a few icons have been added to the vs
code activity bar
each icon focuses on a separate task
within cloud code
if a certain task doesn't apply to your
workflow you can hide it by
right-clicking it
and selecting hide there's also the
addition of the cloud code status bar
seen at the bottom of vs code
from here you can access quick actions
like running and creating a new
application
cloud code commands have also been added
to the command palette
you can access them by pressing command
shift p
and typing in cloud code
let's take a look at the workflows cloud
code supports
first we have cloud code for kubernetes
i'll create a new kubernetes app using
one of the templates
cloud code lets you run debug and view
the logs of your kubernetes apps
this app is ready to go so let's try
running and debugging it
to deploy this app all i need to do is
click the cloud code status bar
and select run on kubernetes
once the deployment is finished click
the link from the log to view your
app running on your local kubernetes
cluster
to debug your app view your code and
place a breakpoint
go back to the status bar and select
debug on kubernetes
once you view your app and triggered the
breakpoint vs code's debugger activates
allowing you to step through your code
if we head to the cloud code for
kubernetes view you'll find the
kubernetes explorer
the kubernetes explorer lets you
visualize all the resources within your
cluster
you can see information like the ipad
rest of your services
and the ports they use this means you
don't have to remember all the core
cli commands to find this info
right clicking on resources provides
contextual links
for actions such as viewing the logs
from pod and opening a connected
terminal
all from within vs code
you can also create a new cluster from
here
next there's cloud code for cloud run
cloud run is our fully managed
serverless product with auto scaling
that scales down to zero
as you can see my google cloud project
already has a couple cloud run services
that are displayed in the cloud run
explorer
with cloud code you can deploy a new
containerized app to cloud run
and view the logs for your cloud run
services
you can also test things out locally
before you deploy by running and
debugging your surface on cloud code's
cloud run emulator
finally there's cloud apis all google
cloud apis are listed here
if you select an api
you're able to quickly enable it
and follow the provided install
instructions
after that you're ready to use it with
your application
yaml authoring assistance is another
pillar of cloud code
cloud code supports a number of
configuration files including kubernetes
resources
like config connector and cloud build
configurations
it also supports over 300 custom
resource definitions
here's a quick example of what yaml
authoring assistance looks like for a
kubernetes config
file by pressing ctrl space
i get a variety of snippets to pick from
after picking one
i can tab through the sections i need to
fill in
by pressing control space again i guess
suggestions
linting catches syntax errors and
hovering over configurations provides
inline documentation
in conclusion cloud code is a tool that
speeds up non-trivial
tedious tasks when developing cloud
native applications
it also reduces friction when creating
gamil configuration files
to learn more about what you can do with
cloud code head to this link
also check out the description below for
more resources
we'll go over other scenarios in future
videos until next time
you